in our series on the new normal we're
looking at how the pandemic is
dramatically changing our everyday lives
and for many people that means not going
to the gym but as much of the country
reopens gyms and fitness centers are
adopting unprecedented safety measures
hoping to welcome their members back but
many people still not comfortable with
the potential risk and so they're trying
it at home and our Vlad duty has been
trying it himself lad I will acknowledge
I have also done this I didn't realize
how much my house shaped until I tried
to do jumping jacks inside of it well so
here's here's what's going on Tony
experts are calling it a digital
disruption of the fitness industry as
more people are using streaming apps and
online classes for their at home
workouts so to get a better
understanding of this I did what you did
Tony I decided to bring the gym right
here into my living room with a little
bit of help on my daily 5-mile run
through New York City's Central Park you
can see it's a nice day as temperatures
rise you might start to see more crowds
in parks jam-packed with people cycling
running and Wow
some fitness centers have been given the
green light to reopen the safety
measures being implemented may not be
enough to entice people still worried
about infection people might not feel as
confident going to a gym in a shared
space whereas they can still confidently
crush their workouts at home in the
confines of their own living room or
kitchen or wherever it is
like many of us Nike Master Trainer
Kirsty God so has been getting her reps
in at home I recently joined her for an
at-home training session you can still
get a great sweat and I think it's an
important time for us to just adapt the
situation that we're in turns out
Americans are adapting to this new
normal
locking the online videos and streaming
apps to get their daily sweat and we're
seeing 400 to 500 percent growth in our
usage Mark Watterson is the president of
I've written an interactive Fitness
technology developed for NordicTrack
Proform and free motion they want this
unbelievable immersive and interactive
experience that is personalized to the
user that is also progressive to the
user staying physically distant
shouldn't prevent you from being
physically active even America's top
doctor is asking people to be more
creative when it comes to staying fit
during quarantine if you don't have
weights at home you can use laundry
detergent or canned goods to provide
that extra resistance I just wanted to
share with you one of my Kevin Bacon
posted his at-home workout routine on
Twitter don't forget to breathe and I do
it twice and NFL wide receiver Davante
Adams found a workout partner in his
eight month old daughter deja many local
gyms are now live-streaming fitness
classes
water bottles and if you are looking for
actual home equipment well you may be
out of luck
this warehouse in Massachusetts can't
keep up with the demand I've actually
run out of spin bikes which brings us
back to my 10-minute workout with Kirsty
got7 without mama Mia that didn't feel
like 10 minutes it felt like a half hour
I'm getting up close to the camera here
there are drops of sweat he heard me
saying it right there it felt like a
half hour I was huffing and puffing way
more than I do for my five-mile runs and
as kursi said you don't really need any
equipment you can use your body weight
and things from around the home like a
towel large bottles of laundry detergent
or backpacks filled with books and Gayle
a reminder Jim's here in New York City
are still closed so take that advice
that's right I'm surprised that you
worked up quite a sweat Vlad in ten
minutes I was really I'm thinking it
would take a look it didn't look as hard
as it didn't look as hard watching you
on tape but clearly you're working up a
sweat and sweats always a good thing
when working out and I didn't know that
there's another use for toilet paper I
saw her kicking around the toilet paper
like the soccer ball okay that'll come
in handy for somebody for somebody I
like the person who used the wine
bottles for weight lifting I thought
that's a great idea
I can vouch for the fact that the
equipment is back is on backorder
because I ordered some weights for at
home back in March and they still
haven't arrived yet so it's a hopeless
if you if you go the wide bottle route
you can always you know lighten the load
as you go you know pull it off drink it
put it down drink it put it down it's a
great exercise thanks very much